على وقع كل هذا التصعيد يبدو بان بابا
تفوضى بين روسيا واوكرانيا حول ايجاد
تسويه للحرب سيغلق نهائيا فبعد الكثير من
الشد والجذب خرج مسؤول الروسي ليقطع الشك
باليقين ويؤكد بالحرف انه لا تسوي على
الاطلاق مع اوكرانيا التصريح جاء من
القائم باعمال مندوب روسيا لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبيينوف الذي نفى اي اتصالات بين
ممثلين روسيا والاتحاد الاوروبي بشان
التفاوضى لانها الحرب
تصريحات المسؤول الروسي جاء تفضلن على
اعلان السكرتير مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني اليكسي داني لوف بان بلاده تلقت
عروضا للدخول في تسويه الازمه الاوكرانيه
تشبه سيناري تسويه الازمه الكوريه والصيغه
الكوريه مشاهدينا تعني الاتفاق الذي تم
على اساسه حل النزاعي بين سول وبيونغ يونغ
سنه 53 وانتهى بتقسيم شبه الجزيره الكوريه
الى شمال